[Music]
hey i'm christian i'm an outdoor
adventure photographer and i've been
living on the road full time for three
and a half years first in my suv and now
in my converted ram promaster i still
have so much footage to sort through
from europe but we still have italy to
get to which i'm really excited to share
i just honestly haven't made time to sit
down and edit when i got back from
europe the weather in washington had
really turned i usually head south at
the first sign of rain but i decided to
stick around for a friend's wedding and
i was really unprepared for just how
dark gloomy and rainy it became
i actually tried filming um a couple
different times and
even at iso 1600 it was really dark and
grainy the the video itself which i
could work with it wasn't that bad but
it was the audio um it was raining
non-stop and when it's like a nice soft
rain it's very calming and i actually
love the sound of rain on the rooftop
but this was just like
it was so loud also i rely on sunshine
for my solar power to power my house
batteries so long story short
i am now in california i actually drove
17 hours yesterday to get here after my
friend's wedding and
i'm on the big sur coast and i love
being down here so super excited side
note please enjoy this lovely view of a
parked car and passing traffic
i'm actually in a parking lot um i tried
filming on the big sur coast this
morning but there were just too many
cars going by and it was super loud
which that's just the reality of van
life sometimes i figured i'd tell you
guys all of that because it ties nicely
into today's topic which is all about
remote work so here are 10 different
ways to earn a remote income while
living on the road number one content
creation so this one is in really high
demand and quickly becoming an essential
part of building brand awareness it's
also one of the most effective ways for
a brand to connect with its consumers
and build a compelling story around the
products and services they aim to sell
you might notice a lot of artists and
influencers calling themselves content
creators and that's mostly just because
not labeling what you do allows you to
expand into other forms of creative
expression photography and videography
for this one there's so many different
options but a few examples would include
portraits weddings um real estate
lifestyle product photography catalog
commercial you could do event
photography um you could also do outdoor
adventure photography which is what i do
nfts are becoming hugely popular and
really really lucrative you could be a
commercial drone pilot so if you got
your license then you could be hired by
other content creators or brands who
create aerial assets that they could
then use in their work or marketing
materials um you can also edit videos
for other content creators so there's so
many different options here writing
writing has infinite possibilities
especially if you're a good writer a few
examples would be blogging guest writing
ghost writing copyright editing um you
could be a novelist with a blog you can
earn money in a lot of different ways so
you could do paid sponsorships with
brands you could do ad revenue so like
allowing google ads to run on your
platform
affiliate marketing is an option where
you would link some of your favorite
products and every time someone clicks
on that link and buys you would earn a
commission you could author ebooks
informational articles uh essays poetry
song lyrics there's honestly so many
options music so if you have any kind of
musical ability if you can sing or play
an instrument or write lyrics
you could do so much with that talent
write songs release albums performance
venues build an audio library you could
license music to other creatives or
brands or to a platform like musicbed or
epidemic sound you could start a youtube
channel teaching people how to play ben
howard on the guitar
i would subscribe on that note you could
start a youtube channel or an instagram
or a tick tock and work towards building
a large following obviously it isn't
guaranteed to make you money but it
might serve as a launching pad to build
awareness around whatever it is you do
and maybe get your work down the line if
you do go this route i would encourage
you to do it because you're passionate
about something and not for any other
reason it actually can be very demanding
work and it isn't always easy to tell
when your brand ends and your personal
life begins so in other words if you
don't love doing it it will definitely
wear you out over time number two social
media marketing creating and posting
pinterest pins or instagram posts
building content calendars for brands
posting on their behalf paid
sponsorships with brands affiliate
marketing ambassadorships you can do
these as an independent contractor for
someone else for example a brand or you
can do it for yourself to drive traffic
to a blog or sell a product or build
your own social media platforms a friend
of mine works as a social media manager
for an outdoor brand and so he handles
all of the content creation and social
media campaigns for that particular
brand so there are different avenues you
can take with this one as well number
three digital marketing and i.t so with
this one you could be a web developer
programmer a coder it specialist graphic
designer illustrator project manager
or positions that require skills like
search engine optimization and email
marketing i have a friend who lives in
her van full time and she's a
photographer and also an amazing
illustrator which she's been able to do
successfully from the road which is
pretty cool number four financial
advisor and bookkeeping so this would
include online trading investing
bookkeeping accounting tax preparation
financial advising and consulting a lot
of this work can be done from just about
anywhere because a lot of financial
software and banking institutions are
online speaking of investing i'm really
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor wealthfront wealthfront is an
automated investing service that uses
software designed by phds to build a
portfolio based on your financial goals
at your risk tolerance and also allows
you to tailor your investments to
include specific sectors and or socially
responsible initiatives that you care
about in my previous corporate life i
maintained a 401k but as a self-employed
freelancer i no longer have an employer
matching my contribution so these days i
dedicate a lot of time to thinking about
how to grow my business and how to save
for retirement and what qualifies as a
good investment i love that while front
is focused on making investing feel like
less of a roller coaster by helping you
build long-term wealth and put your
savings to work i also love that they
have an option to invest in
cryptocurrency trusts which means you
can get exposure to crypto as part of a
diversified portfolio
wealthfront also handles automatic
rebalancing and tax loss harvesting so
you can be as hands-off as you want to
be if you open an account using my link
in the description below you'll get the
first five thousand dollars you invest
manage free for life so be sure to check
it out hello good morning uh it's a new
day we're in a new parking spot and
today we're actually at the beach but uh
still in a parking spot so if you hear
car doors slamming shut really sorry
about that but yes uh let's pick up
right where we left off number five
create and sell goods online i for
example sell photographic prints and
each order is fulfilled directly through
my printer so i don't actually have to
keep any inventory on hand some other
examples for this would be small items
like jewelry or paintings or sketches or
nfts any kind of digital download
essentially anything that requires
little to no physical inventory just so
the storage space isn't an issue and
another option is you can actually rent
out time in your van itself by listing
it on sites like outdoorsy number six
online courses so this would include
workshops or university programs or
social media lives or one-on-one
consultations with the internet and
platforms like google meet and zoom it's
pretty much possible to connect with
anyone in the world these days so if you
have a certain skill set uh go ahead and
book one-on-one consultations and charge
for your time for example i get
contacted sometimes about doing
one-on-one sessions with people that are
interested maybe an embarking on van
life or they might have questions about
social media and stuff like that and i
don't personally do those but it has got
me thinking about putting together a
workshop maybe sometime down the line
and that's actually something i'd love
to hear from you guys about if you would
be interested in something like that my
thoughts are like a in-depth road life
workshop where i address some of your
questions and go into greater detail so
if that is something you're interested
in let me know in the comments below and
maybe drop a question that you would
love to see answered more thoroughly but
anyway back to online teaching options
if you know another language or if you
want to teach english if you have a
skill with maybe makeup or hairdressing
or
how to start a business or relationship
coaching there's so many different
options that you could explore with
one-on-one coaching number seven virtual
assistant this one would cover a wide
variety of tasks but some examples would
be responding to emails or managing
schedules organizing calendars you could
research locations and project
itineraries you could build pitch decks
for clients gather information arrange
travel you could interview and hire
employees remotely you could do expense
tracking data entry there's so many
different options here number eight work
remotely for your current employer if
remote work is something you'd like to
try then i would think of how to best
present it to your current employer in a
way that it's a win-win situation in
some cases as the pandemic has shown us
a lot of us work better from home or in
this case just remotely there are less
distractions less time spent commuting
and also less pressure to socialize
during work time which if you're an
introvert like me can be nice one option
is just ask for trial period and just
kind of see how things go and if the
arrangement's successful then ask for an
extension and yeah continue moving
forward until you're both really
comfortable with the remote work
situation number nine work seasonal jobs
this one's super popular i run into so
many people on the road who will work
for say three to four months at a time
and then
save up a bunch of money and then hit
the road again for more adventures some
examples of this could be rafting and
tour guides or ski instructors surf
instructors summer camp counselors or
national park staff a lot of employers
are really happy to actually have the
extra help during especially peak
holiday seasons and especially at
restaurants cafes bars retail stores
event venues that said if the work isn't
clearly seasonal and you do intend to
leave i think it's important to be
really upfront about that with your
employer when you're being interviewed
um as a previous retail manager i can
say a lot of time and energy goes into
training new employees so it's just
important to be upfront about your
intention to leave and finally number 10
traveling professional so this one is
just like an umbrella for all of the
different professions we didn't really
get to a couple more ideas would just be
traveling nurse or pharmacist therapist
a fitness instructor yoga teacher or my
personal favorite you could be a pet
sitter or a house sitter pet sitting is
something i primarily do because i love
animals and i wish i could have a dog
with me in the van but the truth is i
just i travel through national parks way
too often and also overseas so it just
wouldn't be fair to the dog but one day
one day i will have a dog um but yeah it
actually works really well to also have
a nice break from the road and just to
get to spend time with pets but i do
think it's worth mentioning that it also
does pay and especially once you have a
lot of experience and solid
recommendations pet owners are more than
happy to compensate you for taking
quality care of their home and their
pets alright so that was 10 and here are
some resources and websites to check out
if you're interested in freelance work
or pet setting opportunities i have not
personally tried these all myself but i
have heard good things about quite a few
of them i think that as remote work
becomes more widely accepted and even
more popular just more opportunities and
resources will be available out there
there are a few overhead costs and
considerations necessary to make this
kind of lifestyle possible
most likely you will need a smartphone
and a laptop uh you'll need a dedicated
place to work even if that's just like a
cafe or library or your rig itself and
most elusive of all you will need a
strong internet connection most of the
time i personally use the weiboos signal
booster that helps a lot for amplifying
my cell signal and it comes in really
handy when i'm in remote locations or
out on blm land all of those things
aside i personally love working remotely
i love the freedom to make my own
schedule to be my own boss to take
projects to work with brands and people
that i really believe in and also just
to have the option to pivot whenever i
feel like i need a change there are of
course downsides to being your own boss
and working for yourself and i could
cover that in a whole different video
but for now i'll just leave you with
this and a question i'm curious how many
of you out there actually work remotely
or have worked remotely if you did or do
what do you do and do you like it
alright so that's about it and
thank you so much for watching this
video um i hope that you guys found it
helpful or interesting and if you did
please give it a thumbs up and subscribe
if you're interested in
van life content or travel content and i
will see you guys next time
[Music]
[Music]
you